hey another atom I'm hydrogen nice to
meet you how are you feeling about the
jump hi there i'm anti hydrogen you're
anti atom and to be honest I'm feeling
kind of neutral my positron and
antiproton balance out just like your
electron and proton right hey yeah you
look just like me but different somehow
well be careful if we get too close will
disappear in a spark of energy I'd like
to stay in one piece oh wow sorry it's
okay I was just thinking it's kind of
weird for us to be chatting like this
before a jump above CERN why is that
well for starters how do we know we'll
both fall of course we'll fall it's
gravity you know the force of attraction
between masses I even know how fast we
should fall Galileo showed in that tower
experiment that all falling objects
accelerate at the same rate regardless
of mass that's for bigger objects it's a
different story for small particles like
us our mass is so tiny that the
gravitational force we experience is
miniscule and if the particles are
charged like my anti proton or your
proton then it becomes impossible to
detect compared to the much greater
electromagnetic force acting on them but
that's only for charged particles you
and I are both neutral our charges
balance out so the electromagnetic force
is small and the gravitational force
should be detectable I know mine's been
measured because you're everywhere but
I'm kind of hard to find why is that
anyway shouldn't there have been an
equal amount of matter and antimatter
created in the Big Bang you'd think so
then all of those particles would have
annihilated each other into energy
remember and the universe is obviously
full of matter no one knows why there's
more matter than antimatter which is why
scientists are so interested in studying
me so where did they find you anyway
actually I was made in that lab down
there they needed an accelerator to make
my antiproton because it's so heavy just
as heavy as your proton getting my
positron was easier it's much lighter
like your electron and there are
materials that naturally decay by
emitting one then they just had to put
the two
and they got me but it's only recently
that they've been able to keep me around
long enough to study my properties and
now they've sent you on this jump with
me hey wait a minute that's right we're
re-enacting Galileo's experiment but
with matter and antimatter instead of
two objects made of matter so what's
going to happen are you gonna fall
upwards or something only one way to
find out